[Music]
it's folly bullies news Rolly pollies
submitted by JK come to Pasadena that's
enticing we're practically there yeah
we're talking about latina California
probably and then what always blows my
mind when people say like come to our
city right like right when we came back
from Paris there was a JK new submission
and they're like submitted by someone so
please come to Paris we were just there
like two weeks ago they don't even care
about our lives I don't even like keep
up to where we've been do they just want
us to go and enjoy that city I hope to
run into it they want to meet up with
you Oh
meeting great appreciate the love I was
very mean to somebody in Paris actually
because yeah because of how he
approached me and how he'd said how he
talked to me I was pissed and even even
Mario was angry for me so we're just a
number one like when I'm in Paris I
don't think knows me it's like a
different country I don't know how many
people watched me out in pairs so I'm
sitting there and this guy goes let me
get a picture and I was like what let me
get a picture and I looked at him I was
like what the [ __ ] is your name
I was so irritated it's like let me get
a picture and he was like oh my bad man
I mean like these let me get takes this
oh snap right where he's like trying to
be funny like I can tell he's around a
dumb caption layer I grabbed his phone
like delete like smile I just took it
away I was like when you approach
somebody don't demand from them I was
just like you let me get a picture and
you like you what the [ __ ] you say to me
he's like you're standing front of the
Mona Lisa
[Laughter]
you bet it would like outside on the
loom it's like a hope you're so odd
because like you're sitting there and
it's just a line full of people
what the [ __ ] thing is gonna yeah I'm
mother I think that uh you're talking to
me you know
I'm just sitting there I mean I think he
kind of thought I was ignoring him right
Mike first of all [ __ ] I don't know
where anybody is from he tried to
gangster a picture out of you [ __ ] you
are [ __ ] he probably thought in his
head he was saying hi my name is Bob
blah nice to meet you but I think is so
nervous that they just put up a gangster
front yeah listen I get nervous too
I don't do that [ __ ] I've taken pigeon
the people who are like shaking
they're very nice yeah I don't mind that
but you you have the you have the
weirdest picture encounters yeah dude
yeah I mean I thought in my encounters
were bad but when I hear your stories
I'm like hey dude and a college show he
grabbed my [ __ ] ass and I literally
slapped him upside the head full force
just like nah that's not it try to be
funny in front of his friend worse you
know I mean so we're taking the pills
like oh let's take a peak crash class I
went
[Applause]
come on you like that because you're a
comedian yeah they could just say
whatever he was trying told me that's
I'm not a comedian
damn an Irish model had to flee her home
after being attacked by cyber bullying
way she had to run away she had to run
away from the cyber there on the
computer
oh yeah very funny comedian said I can't
remember what it was is like why can't
you just turn onto your computer I think
that's a great line and it's like you're
being cyber bullied so turn off your
computer yeah I don't I don't think it
ends there I mean I just happened to me
when I was a kid back in those lol
chatroom days and these gangsters would
hit me up supposedly and be like I know
where you live this is your address I
know your mom just went to the bank and
got this Scott Riggs well that's not
what they're going through brah
I ever bully that's a that's an actual
stalker yeah I see what she's running
away the TOI I thought I knew it once
your parents are like politicians and
they're known write a little different
well how would they know my mom is like
got a college dad works at City Hall pal
yeah like she'll like that but those are
like off our stuff well yeah but
cyberbullying it's very not real yeah
it's like you're a loser look how ugly
are you stupid [ __ ] go die what
you know you're thinking about thugs
that found out how to use the internet a
little different I guess that's how the
minimum was back then for cyber bullying
oh yeah cyber bullying as we know it was
really hardcore that was our level yeah
that's just real life SS this model and
brand ambassador named Debbie she's 25
she's from Ireland but she is living in
Bali cuz she have to run away from the
haters what she was saying is that she
felt that she didn't have enough support
in Indonesia like from the police or any
well she had to run away from Indonesia
yeah oh I thought she was like I gotta
get out of Ireland I'm going to Bali to
get away from the haters no she left
Bali because apparently there were a lot
of haters online saying that her light
like just complaining about her life
that were saying things like you're not
gonna be able to live leave your Villa
like they were just trying to scare her
and I guess it worked because she ended
up leaving so this is Debbie
prove them wrong she's now in New
Zealand she just said that she felt that
she had no support from local
authorities so she didn't she feared for
her probably didn't even know what cyber
bullying was this is Indonesia it's like
one comment for example would you like
to read yes please that's a long
so-and-so her name dances at cocoon
parties for a living cry faces only Jett
she's able to get on as if she lands a
job as a stewardess and even then that's
a stretch of the imagination you should
pass on the word that a few of us are
into her and she needs to stop
pretending all preaching that she's the
owner of five companies and four cafes
around Asia and designs her own clothing
line what clothing line
and cafes and companies does she have
Westermarck read visas full-blood lies
if she continues on that path lying to
people I'm gonna out her so bad she's
gonna be too ashamed to shimmy out her
home for fear of what people will know
but judging by her skinny bruised up
weird legs she doesn't go far cocaine
ice not sure but she's high and all her
bloody youtube vids it's funny as hell
and we had a great laugh when we
accidentally stumbled into that morons
page she is such a try [ __ ] it's
unreal she ran away from that or is that
one of the cyberbullying because that
just sounds like criticism in the
article showing like some of the cyber
bullying I mean you know what you can do
is swipe and delete it's longer thing
else you can also block I do that a lot
yeah I don't like this comment Brock but
then she can't be a potential victim
though Oh a lot of people that read this
article they kept saying like okay all
of the photos so like I'm showing you
more all of the photos on the article is
just of her modeling yeah and yours
eternally wet yeah one photo of like
evidence of the cyberbullying and so
people were just like this is just to
promote her like herself so don't don't
don't investigate and try to like go on
her page yeah I'm not a media and we're
helping her we're giving her a free
we're giving her free promotion let go
back to that previous pic [ __ ] eats like
that let's say you you strawberry this
is a [ __ ] who eat strawberry with a fork
you know what a lot of people a lot of
good hard-working people that's a
character you know I think if they can
know that's a strawberry dude oh I don't
know [ __ ] okay know what the play-doh
there's a biscuit mashed potatoes
carrots greens yes she Thanksgiving she
missed a shot of then she's like the
trash my question is she actually owns
five cafes and all that stuff yeah
figure that out too but I couldn't find
but she left all her businesses like
that is cyberbullying I guess but how
why are you running away from that
everything said she also cuz you know
how I mentioned she's a brand ambassador
so she was also mentioning in the
article that a lot of these brands that
she works with were even concerned about
her safety because they were sending her
messages like are you okay like oh
you're so lying you dumb [ __ ] I want to
see comments of people wanting to kill
her and stuff I think that's I need to
see death threats you [ __ ] gobbler
because if that's not true you are such
a lying [ __ ] and then she's like here
the death method you're like oh thank
you cobbler I say this though if it was
that sir she what she would have showed
all that [ __ ] and they would have been
reported a hundred percent
dude she had to leave no no she didn't
report it but the her her argument is
that the cops there didn't give a [ __ ]
no I'm saying like that's the most
mundane one that they found out of
because if and that's the example of
extreme don't [ __ ] buy it that's cuz
the cops can read is why they didn't
care because we're like the longest one
I want to see the death threats or even
like a death threat emoji or something
look at knife there's a deck with the
face there's a knife in the skull face
yeah I don't think that you're a good
example for Indonesian bald belizean
children maybe what's your dog so
whenever somebody talks [ __ ] you get to
just take your money and [ __ ] run
away
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you [ __ ] she was saying
is that she she just didn't feel safe
that she left thousands of dollars of
her possessions behind them so it like
with her boyfriend as well and so
they're just they just had to bail out
yeah and they're saying that they
weren't able to do these non-refundable
flights the to travel around Asia and
she's just saying like these people were
out to destroy my life and I had to run
away with cyber bullied follows you
anywhere that's why it's cyberbullying
so what the [ __ ] are you talking about
you need to run away from this cuz after
that they can't like triangulate your
location but maybe you should stop
geo-tagging your photos you [ __ ]
dumbass
it's probably
probably a genius way to promote herself
I got your say like summer saying that
it might be self promotion like a fake
you know I think that's what it is
well that's what a lot of people I don't
get it man I don't know if she really is
the owner of five cafes and all that
stuff it's like do you mean she's smart
as a battery too busy running that stuff
and you know doing work I just love that
we called her worse names than they did
in the thing my whole living off a cyber
bullying is because there's a lot of
like Instagram models out there that are
actually just hookers now she's a hooker
do basically set up this like fake
lifestyle that's paid through hooker ism
and a lot of little girls look up to
that and then they wish one day they can
be as glamorous and live this life they
don't know that they're getting like you
know pissed on and whatever in the
background they don't know and in girls
look that's like that's [ __ ] horrible
I'm saying she's teaching people like if
you have money you could run away from
your problems
everybody did you [ __ ] hope and it
would I see like CEO in their profile
they label what and there's nothing on
it about their business like if you own
the business you would use your
following to kind of promote it that's
just natural but here's the thing
because of taxes they probably do have
an S corp in there for the CEO
like it's just you know this [ __ ] is
true it's just shitty is fun I'm a CEO
as well hey guys would you think of that
video I know you loved it so make sure
to hit that like button to watch more
videos check it out up here